everyone this is Kim from the chess
website calm and today we're gonna be
looking at the final day of the 2018 st.
Louis rapid and blitz tournament they
played nine games of blitz today five
minutes on the clock
three seconds added for every move that
they make we're gonna be looking at the
game from round 15 of the blitz portion
24 round overall in the tournament they
did play nine rounds of rapid before the
blitz portion our competitors whites
gonna be played by a maxim MVL as many
people know him and blacks gonna be
played by Fabiano Caruana
the American who will be facing Magnus
cross and later this year for the World
Championship both of these players
coming into round 15 are in contention
to win this thing their third and fourth
place respectively some of it will come
down to how they fare against those
players above them which they do play
later in the tournament but this was an
exciting game that I wanted to go over
today so MBL's gets a started with pawn
to e4 pawn e5 Knight f3 and Knight to c6
Bishop to b5 the right Lopez which we
see quite often but inside the Berlin
defence which we almost see exclusively
at Knight to f6 instead we see pawn to
a6 Bishop to a4 and then Knight to f6
so castle on the King side Bishop to e7
getting into the close defense a little
bit different sometimes we'll see just a
pawn come down to b5 right away Bishop
to b3 and then black has a lot of
different options from here pawns d6
being at the main one so a little bit
interesting for us to see something
different the close defense not the most
common at the highest level play Bishop
to e7 pawn to d3 more common for white
to play rook to e1 or pawn to d4 Peter
Svidler actually did a video series on
pawn to d3 it's not extremely common up
into this point but I feel like ever
since that video series came out we've
seen more and more players play this one
of the highly respected players out
there so anytime he comes up with
a new variation in the Rye Lopez a lot
of players take notice so after pawn to
d3 then we get into what we expected to
see earlier and pawn to b5 kicking the
bishop back here to b3 pawn d6
solidifying the pawn chain and then pawn
to a3 something Bobby Fischer used to do
quite a bit bring the bishop here to b3
push this pawn 4 to a3 has a little safe
haven right here on a 2 when your
opponent has their pawns on e5 and e6
does open up the door for the
LightSquared Bishop to really control
this long light square diagonal the King
is the only piece defending the square
on f7 so can just put a lot of pressure
on your opponent they always have to be
thinking about what is this Bishop doing
is my King in a safe spot and in a blitz
game that can take its toll on his
opponent Fabiano castles on the King
side Knight to c3 development from
White's pawn to h6 stopping the knight
coming up here to g5 as well as the
bishop coming to g5 many times I think
players are gonna just snap play pawn to
h3 it's the easiest it's gonna be doing
the same thing stopping the bishop
coming down to g4 as well as the Knights
but White has other plans and he plays
Bishop to e3 just centralizing the
Bishop rook to e8 centralizing as well
and then pawn to e4 and this is a spot
where many times players make mistakes
because they're just not sure what to do
okay all my pieces have developed how do
I continue pawn to h3 makes a lot of
sense you can't make too many mistakes
playing something like this but you
could also just play rook to e1
centralizing your rooks is always a good
idea Knight to d5 just starting to
attack your poet you can always you know
think about where they can go and how
they can attack black doesn't have a lot
of strong attacks right here you know if
he wants to bring his own knight down
here to d4 you have both the Knights and
the bishop attacking it but in the game
we see pawn to a4 Fabiano pushes pawn
before it really forces the knight to
now come up here to d5 so white may have
thought that he'd get that eventually
pushing the pawn further in the meantime
Knight comes to a5 attacking the bishop
bishop comes back a to Knight takes
bishop comes up here so white does lose
little tempo because you did have to
move the bishop back and then capture
but black also has the knight over here
on a5 does not want to hold the knight
here on a five it's not doing anything I
always want your Knights in the center
of the boar so be interesting to see how
Fabiano gets this back involved into the
game because right now not helping at
all
pawn to c6 forcing the bishop bit back
Bishop to a2 pawn to c5 so blacks done a
good job of pushing his pawns on the
Queen side of the board does have a
backward pawn here on d6 that white can
eventually start to attack not under any
huge pressure right now but you can see
clearly that black is starting to push
on the Queen side of the board that's
where he sees his advantage on the white
side looks at it and says okay my
advantage is gonna be on the King side
so he he starts to maneuver his knight
Knight here - D - then after Bishop to a
g5 pawn to f4 so you always want to be
taking the initiative with the white
pieces especially in a blitz game so
starting to attack on the King side
since that is his best path forward is
definitely the way to go so pawns who
have four pon takes Bishop takes and
then the bishop comes down here to e6
could have exchanged but decided not to
just develop his LightSquared Bishop
Bishop takes here rook recaptures on e6
Bishop takes in the Queen takes don't
want to capture with your pawn right
here one you know don't want to just
give yourself double pawns if you don't
want if you don't have to also weakens
just the defense in front of the King
but now the Queen comes up here to h5
pawn to f6 not the pawn chain that you
want and then just Queen down here to g4
forcing the rook to move you don't have
a very active Queen right now it's
blocked off how do you get involved into
the game not very easy so definitely the
right path to just go ahead and take
with the Queen here on g5 y continues
with rook up here to f5 attacking the
Queen Queen moves back to e7 Knight down
to F one rook to e5 rook comes back to F
to pawn d5 there is the pawn takes and
then the rook captures here on d5 this
is a spot where I think Black has an
opportunity to
to not take right away yes he's down
upon in material but he can start to
push forward get a better position and
then take that material what I mean is
Queen to d6 allows him to take this
material the only way to protect this
pawn is if you see pawn pushed forward
to c4 which you can actually on passant
and take with your pawn right here this
pawn would would leave to move a lot of
people don't recognize but you could do
that the other option would be Knight to
e3 we could all see why this is bad the
rook is just gonna take that right here
so I think Queen to d6 allows black to
really maneuver all of the pieces in the
center of the board and then eventually
take the pawn only win black once - in
the game decides to go and take with the
rook on d5 Queen to f3 attacking the
rook rook to a d8 and then Knight up
here - III that's hacking the rook
we're cover here to e5 so let's let's
take a look at what that may look like
if it was different maybe Queen to d7
instead then we could see Queen to f3
rook over here to e8 rook to d1 since we
could see not really doing too much if
the knight gets involved into the game
but if the Queen takes okay I think this
is gonna be completely fine for Black
Keys controlling the Sooner of the board
this setup is better for black in my
opinion but in the game decides to go
ahead and take with his rook after the
Queen comes over here they've doubled up
on the deef I'll probably want to be
doubling up on the open e file but
that's where we are Knight - III rook to
e5 Knight to e2 f5 excuse me attacking
the Queen and now Fabiano actually took
the most time he has in the game so far
at about 50 seconds but keep in mind the
only has five minutes total us when
you're thinking that long you're also
thinking while your opponent's going
that's a long time he's just not really
sure in this position how to continue as
Queen is under attack he decides to go
for a rook to e1 we do see an exchange
on the board Queen comes down here to e1
rook to f1 just stopping the attack and
then Queen
back to e5 in VL continues with poncy c3
we do see an exchange there on c3 and
then King to h7 did have the option to
just take here on c3 I think if he does
this it's gonna end up in a trawl
neither player wants a draw they have an
opportunity to win I definitely get in
the top two in this tournament a drawl
you only get half a point in the blitz
portion so you don't want to be drawing
and both sides have a pretty aggressive
position not a lot of time on the clock
either side can win this game from here
Knight to e7 since white is down and
material he almost has to play this line
Queen to f7 and then after the Queen
takes here on d3 then there's just gonna
be a repetitive check and there's going
to end up being a draw from here so
black not looking to do that the sides
instead to go ahead and play King to h7
pawn to a d4 pawn takes pawn takes and
then Queen up here to e6
now why continues to be aggressive he
brings his queen over here to c3
attacking the knight here on a5 which
Fabiano has done a poor job although
it's difficult where was the knight
gonna be going and win but it's still
just hanging out over here on a 5 so
white definitely has the upper hand as
far as active pieces on the board
rook down here to a d5 another option he
had would be to play Queen to b6 I like
this better
it adds another attacker on the square
here on d4 and it also defends this
knight on a 5 which he's going for but
decides to play rook down here to d5
Knight to e3 attacking the rook rook
comes over here to a g5 and then the
pend pushes forward to d5 and it's
always tricky you never know what your
opponent is up to we see black play
Queen to e5 he underestimated the pawn
pushing forward and maybe he thought
that he would try to bring the rook over
and start to push but what he didn't see
was Queen to d3
King comes back here to g8 and then this
pawn starts pushing forward and this is
just another thing that black has to
deal with he doesn't have a knight
involved into the game White has a
pretty aggressive position right here he
has a passed pawn pushing it and so now
black has to spend a lot of time trying
to defend this knight to c6 pawn
continues to push forward with d7 and
now an even more questionable move and
that is Queen to e7 if your opponent is
right here on the seventh rank you
really need to stop that from pushing
yes he has the night here on c6 they can
take that but you just don't even want
to have to worry about exchanging your
Knights if your opponent can double up
here bring the recover it's here to d1
just play Knight to d8 just stop him
from ever pushing is the way to go he
plays Queen to e7 and now Knight to f5
attacking the Queen things get tricky
the knight is being defended both by the
Queen and the rook right here how does
black continue he brings his queen to c5
check King to h1 sure kind of a yeah
what are you gonna do now Knight to DA
but you can see how different it is for
it with Knight or white already has his
night here on f5 so a much better
position for white and at the end of day
blacks just a few moves late getting
that Knights here to d8 Queen to e4 just
preparing the Queen coming to be 8 not
much black can do here Queen to b6
protecting the night here on a d8 so
when the Queen does go duck come up here
you can't just take this knight but
that's not what is on White's mind he's
looking for the checkmate Queen to e 8th
King to h7 and then Knight to e7 and
this is going to be checkmate in a
couple moves there's no way for black to
stop this and at the out at the end of
this move particular Fabiano decides to
go ahead and resign so congratulations
to nvl for winning this game in blitz
around 1520 fourth overall 27 needed to
win out to get the first prize he ended
up going draw draw win
he ended up winning the last game
against Nakamura
unfortunately for MBL Nakamura just
crushed the entire day and even with a
loss Nakamura was able to capture the
overall title of the blitz and rapid
section so they they put all the points
together for an overall winner Nakamura
with 22 and a half points is your winner
in second place with 21 and a half
points is in VL so did set himself self
up for a second place finish one point
behind that Nakamura in third place we
do have mom and dad off which we saw a
few games played extremely well
fourth place Fabiano so although he did
fall in this game played an extremely
strong tournament he led through the you
know the rapid portion was dominating
that for the first few days ended up
stumbling in the Blitz portion not to
finish he was looking for but all this
was really just preparation for him for
the World Championship
fifth place we did have Levon Aronian
with 18 points interesting his last
place we had vision on with 13 and a
half points so 9 points off the leader
and he actually beat the leader in the
first round of the rapid we did go over
that game Vichy verse naka more so how
things changed from that round one that
we looked at till the final round of 27
so hopefully you guys enjoyed the
coverage of the 18 st. Louis rapid and
blitz tournaments will have some more
tournament coverage throughout the rest
of the year
finalized by the world championship in
November so thanks again for watching
I'll see you guys next time